sova kg de déchets c'est le bilan de la
matinée réalisés par les élèves du lycée
dumont d'urville
pour cette activité ils étaient une
centaine divisés en plusieurs groupes
objectif couvrir un maximum de termes
détritus trouvés n'ont d'ailleurs pas
surpris les étudiants les masques des
mégots des bouteilles de verre des
canettes des bouteilles de plastique
c'est des choses un peu auquel on
s'attendait heureusement en fait on
s'est réuni entre éco délégués pour
organiser cet événement est motivé le
plus de lycéens possible afin de leur
faire prendre conscience à la
dégradation qui est fait par tous les
fers de lance de cette action sont les
éco-délégués mise en place pour la
deuxième année consécutive ils sont une
quinzaine d'élèves volontaires agir en
faveur du développement durable puisque
c'était la première année qui s'était
mis en place c'était notamment de faire
de la sensibilisation sur le
développement durable pour que les
élèves sachent de pouce que c'est en
fait en première ma du coup commencé les
actions concrètes telles que le
recyclage du papier dans les classes
également montrer la quantité de pain
gaspillés chaque semaine à la cantine la
sensibilité à l'environnement est de
rigueur au lycée dumont d'urville
les élèves sont concernés et pilotes
eux-mêmes leurs actions cela fait déjà
pratiquement un an et demi que qu'ils
réfléchissent à des solutions au niveau
local pour changer finalement notre
façon d'appréhender l'environnement le
monde dans lequel ils vivent
d'autres actions sont en cours de
réflexion entre les éco délégués du
lycée avec cet objectif de poursuivre la
sensibilisation sur le développement
durable